good afternoon 47. your destination is
marrakech morocco
where civil riots are looming your
targets are private banker klaus
strandberg
and army general reza zedan two of the
conspirators in a sinister plot to
overthrow morocco's fragile government
strandberg a former bank ceo who stole
billions of dollars worth of savings
from the moroccan people
was facing trial for investment fraud
but early this morning
a band of heavily armed mercenaries
freed strandberg from his prison
transport
resulting in the death of several police
officers
stranbert now takes refuge at his native
swedish consulate
in front of which crowds of angry
protesters have gathered
demanding his hand over to moroccan
authorities
we believe general zeidan orchestrated
strandberg's escape to infuriate the
public
and spark nationwide riots allowing
zaidan to impose martial law
operating out of a field hq at a nearby
abandoned school
he will no doubt use the riots to depict
the rabbat government
as weak and inept and persuade the
general staff to support a fully-fledged
military coup
in the name of national security
our client building contractor hamilton
lowe
who stands to lose a fortune in
government contracts
has hired us to prevent the coup d'etat
to do so
you need to paralyze zedan's rebel
forces and prevent the riots from
escalating further
hence the double contract this is quite
the political powder cake 47
so be careful the fate of a nation is at
stake
i will leave you to prepare
uh
welcome to marrakech 47 the situation
grows more tense by the minute
the consulate is under lockdown but the
protests are only a stone throw away
from full-blown riots
and they dan won't hesitate to unleash
his troops so whatever you're planning
time is of the essence good luck 47
all right there there should be room for
all here man
that's okay no he is capitalism
i mean that
i'll want this date
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
much
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
seven billion
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
man we might have a situation i'll check
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
clear
[Applause]
[Applause]
what's going on
thanks for spotting some quickly never
expected something like this
how to locate clouds
hey trooper sir this is a restricted
area you're gonna have to
please go to the reception desk
uh
okay ace if you're not worried i'm not
worried
say what no i'm done here
hello soldier
recruit
according to the appointment schedule
klaus strandberg has booked a massage to
relieve his back pains
no doubt all that time in prison has
caused muscle stiffness
the masseur who works at a local clinic
has apparently already checked into the
building
massage
what's going on someone's been hurt it
looks really bad
i'm going to see if i can help
this is messed up i mean
massage
yes
please proceed to the massage room it's
upstairs on the right
i'll inform mr strandberg
please go to the massage room
sorry i have to search you sir
uh sir sorry this is just gonna take a
second
thanks sir you're clean
ah so the man with the golden touch
let's get started shall we ah
this muscle tension is killing me why
don't you lie down mr streinberg
oh please call me close
hey you shaved your head connie nice
well done 47 i will leave strandberg in
your capable hands
what is it now really
that's the ticket i tell you
nothing makes you tense like thousands
of people wanting to kill you
talk it down next up raises a down
massage guy yeah right of course
[Applause]
best
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
sorry you need to leave please leave now
hey holstered that thing
holy crap
fatigue utility belt black jackets
the whole thing at a soldier five
man
so what did he do the prisoner
we just refer to each other by our first
names wanda
and we try to be as respectful as
possible number four
take
sir what the hell are you doing don't
move
[Music]
could you possibly id this bastard i
can't help you
there's gotta be way there's always a
way
think say damn it think
check every square inch boom
roger
let's stand down target is in the
vicinity look alive
she'll find out that he's been cheating
on her and stab him in his sleep
and i'll be there watching front row
seats
please step back
he'll never believe i was a traitor if
he finds the tapes
he'll put two and two together he'll
avenge me
take his time too reza
will pay for this
that is general ray's
target's gone
command this is big dog you copy someone
is killing people
he was disguised as one of my men
not a tree
nice and easy boys now let them come to
us let's head back
affirmative standing down
have been determined any leakage
could endanger the whole operation
over there
i have nothing here
[Applause]
no sign of the target
targets
[Music]
stick around for another round
i lost visual
visual
now
are you waiting for wash them out
[Applause]
i have to ask you to kindly exit the
premises i will not
walk through here today thank you
we're clear nothing here
so
[Applause]
[Music]
the printing crew spreads fake
propaganda in the name of crystal dawn
the pan-african liberation movement this
encourages moroccan citizens
to rise up and take justice into their
own hands
which of course is exactly what zeidan
is counting on
very clever now according to the
printing schedule
the crew is out hanging posters and they
are likely to wear masks
me
hey
what command
thought i heard something checking it
out
ah
so
his brother was one of the policemen who
got killed on the merc's attack
strandberg's prison transport this
morning
so he uh got cold feet
tried to blow the lid on the whole
operation
according to the soldiers the condemned
prisoner in the cell was a close friend
of zedan
however when his brother a marrakesh
police officer was killed during
stranberg's breakout
the prisoner decided to betray zaidan
and go public
alas he was caught before he could
thwart the kubata
the hell you doing up there monkey boy
[Applause]
there you go
right there hello sir
this is the second time i've told you to
comply and come with me
my patience is running out and when i
feel impatient
i tend to shoot people alright so come
on
now you are going to follow me nice and
easy stay calm and you'll be fine
understood
raquel she'll kill him she'll find out
that
he's been cheating
[Music]
now
oh
so
[Applause]
you're in good work 47. now to locate
general zeddan
probably deserves it
what's going on
can you tell me
is a pretty good
in my position
is
at ease
i'm not sure i've seen you before who
are you
i give up
[Applause]
you're in good work 47 now to locate
general zaydan
[Applause]
squad
that is general reyes as a dan keeper of
peace
both targets down now head towards an
exit
so
[Music]
anyone choppy still
area is clear please advise over
okay we need to man up
eat up
here
[Applause]
attention this is
carry on okay what's up
i salute
i'm very sorry
compromise but i i don't understand
there is no sign of forced entry no
alarms nothing
one of my people has gone missing in
johannesburg
a key bearer i wish i'd been informed
still the system demands two keys and
the rest are all accounted for
accept free elite predecessors comp
but this plane went down over the
pacific
it was an accident such was the
conclusion at the time
yes
people die mr fanon happens all the time
even to us
it seems like a conspiracy probably
isn't
and yet the failed coup in morocco
the ether virus
someone knows about us
there was a pattern and i failed to see
it
providence is under attack
how much was that
[Music]
money some money mr fennen
information on all of our assets and
operatives
like you
[Music]
take a trench director and make it a
deep one
because none of you are safe anymore
you